what do you make of this recent market
volatility is this part of a normal
cycle or does it seem I mean the Mohamed
el-erian has said we're in a perfect
storm that doesn't seem like a normal
cycle well Stephanie I think that
volatility is normal fits of volatility
I wrote a memo recently and I talked
about my friend sandy who the airline
pilot who describes his job as hours of
boredom punctuated by moments of terror
and that is the description of the
investor's job one more time hours of
boredom once you're up to by moments of
terror that's how you describe investor
life well I think that's right and and
this is one of the you know the last six
weeks in the in the stock market have
been one of those moments of terror but
it's normal the the reasons are not
quite normal I mean we have we have kind
of one-off I think that people have
gotten used to dealing with normal
economic cycles that recession recovery
etc but we have now kind of cosmic
issues that people don't have any
experience dealing with and don't know
how China oil rates terrorism are just
are just for example is the fear
exaggerated or punctuated by the
presidential election when you see
Donald Trump up there you know dare I
say putting fear in the US economy
really speaking in such declarative
statements about the disaster a
situation that we're in does that affect
the markets I can't tell you
definitively because I don't have any
research on that subject but i would
guess so they're scaring the hell out of
people and you know Donald says the
Chinese are killing us the Mexicans are
killing us the Japanese are killing us
but we're going to get the jobs back and
i think that people tend to believe him
then the others compete to be equally
dramatic and dramatic they can't you
know it's very hard for them to compete
with him by saying no the you know the
latest information from the Commerce
Department says it's not really they
don't want to hear that his stuff is
much more
headline worthy Howard I'm not sure how
much market volatility that contributes
to right that's more social volatility
if you look at this chart though you can
see for example the volatility in oil 30
de volta lien oil has risen to a
seven-year high and you could argue that
would have happened with or without
Donald Trump's insane hairdo right well
I'm sure that's true i doubt if he has
much to do with the price of oil I'm
just talking about mood but this has a
lot to do with the moments of terror in
the equity markets yes but Matt it
drives me a little crazy because I was
listening to what you said before and
you talked about the car makes us crazy
all the end and you know oil prices up
stocks doing better why why you well
because asset classes get very tightly
correlated in times of fear right but
all is not an asset class people don't
have investments in oil for the most
part who do you know who has a position
in oil I believe that higher prices of
her oil are bad for our economy on
balance and bad for Japan a bed for
Europe all the places that import it but
don't make it we imports more than we
send out we are a net importer but we
make some but I oil prices are not
necessarily good for us I I think that
the fact that stock prices go up when
oil prices go up really proves that most
people don't know how these things work
could it let me just ask one final what
do you mean by that do you think I think
that ETFs are maybe one of the reasons
that the popularity of ETFs are one of
the reasons that that correlation gets
stronger I think you're probably right
because I think that ETFs for some
people are a way to gamble if if most
people wanted to take a position on oil
in the pre ETF days it would have been
very challenging and today it's very
easy and they can get in and they can
get out and and they have a pure-play
most other oil companies in the past had
other businesses coal or other things
and so I do think that there is a
component whereas all
derivatives trading has basically made
it easier to bet short-term speculation
than it was in the past so how I want to
go back to the question of how afraid
people really are I mean I'm looking at
the Vics right now maybe you can pull
that up the fear index so-called fear
and is in the Vics and it's actually at
22 which I don't think historically is
that terribly high and it was far higher
back in November if you go back so it's
it's not at its historic I are people
that afraid do you think oh well take
back to August yeah well how about
showing a 10-year chart you're talking
about day-to-day I don't care here's
here's just back tomorrow Heda spiked we
actually went up in Portland but do it
Howard asked to well that was China take
it back a Western that was China that we
were since that was the tipping point in
the market that was when the market went
from incredibly complacency
obliviousness in denial too I don't know
what's going on I better get out fast
but here's your tenure chart now it's up
a little bit but I just I'm wondering
how do you how do you measure that you
say people prices well I mean I'm not a
student of the Vics but I mean what this
shows is that you you had an all-time
high on this chart at the at the global
financial crisis you had a panic in the
summer of 11 in connection with the
budget follies and the downgrade of US
debt and then you had a spike in the
summer of 15 with China and now we're at
we're at a high level but for those
bikes so I think that in general if you
look at the last year it's higher than
most of the other years